[Music]
why is dream specs way better than real
sex because they come when you want them
to girl that is so true when not done
they're done hello
ever think about all the stuff we've
done and wonder how we did not die it's
a cultural thing we are too bad as
planes like those [ __ ] ways wonder
woman we worked our asses off we've
opened up our own store we'll win it
we're four hundred and ninety-three
thousand dollars in debt I'm Clara Luna
I am going to invest 1.7 million dollars
on you
but in my experience business and
friendship don't always mix you don't
have to worry your pretty little head my
head is not little it's just that my
breasts are humongous you want to be a
businesswoman you're gonna have to act
like a boss you have to fire him what
don't hate me hate mail was her idea
witness my introducing a new product at
her launch party she just wants to steal
our idea we don't break this bitch's
back
[Music]
[Music]
I'll punch that [ __ ] in the face I
would marry you if I was in the coochie
those two peppers they are very spicy
just a little sliver goes a long way
your peppers are really hot goats milk
so to coat the throat
[Music]